trained by Joe Rogan podcast by night
all day they come in they weigh in then
once we record it make sure they're cool
they can rehydrate they have many many
more hours to rehydrate so guys were
rehydrating six hours earlier most guys
showed up at 10:00 a.m. they made weight
and then they had way more time so when
you saw people stand on the scale I was
saying official weight when I was
announcing it
they had weighed in at 10 o'clock in the
morning so it was already 4:00 in the
afternoon
these guys were hydrated and thick no
one looks sick so at least visually no
one looked like like Conor McGregor
looked when he fought Chad Mendes when
they weighed in he looked like it's a
different person does he a dead man
cheeks were all sucked it looks horrible
I mean look he did good in the fight
yeah but he really did cut he cuts a lot
to get to 145 he's a big boy yeah he's a
big boy he's way bigger than like Choza
Aldo and Josie Aldo was cutting a lot at
one point his career I by the way I've
never had a hardcore fan I've never
enjoyed a fight more than I enjoyed Nate
Diaz Conor McGregor's I've never lost my
mind so much at the end of the fuge Diaz
fan yeah and that was just incredible I
mean I'm ten days notice yeah well that
whole to card or that to fight event the
two fights the final fights the Holly
Holm Miesha Tate was one of the most
exciting endings to any fight ever
when Misha took Holly down in the fifth
round a fight where she was losing it
took her back and choked her that's
insane yeah I read an article today
where someone was saying that it was
that me she'd lost virtually every
second it was from a guy respect a
writer and I was she won the second I
what are you talking about the second
round she took her down and pounded her
I think they did they give her a 10-8
yes they just gave and they should she
dominated so I read this article this is
ESPN writer Rhoda and I was like wait a
minute man come on you can't say that
like why are you saying that like that's
that's silly hyperbole right it doesn't
even make any sense
um and me show it was threatening in the
third and fourth after that Holly was on
her bike she's like [ __ ] this yeah like
she's fighting perfect and super
cautious with no chances and barely
winning those rounds you know just
winning them but barely winning it
wasn't nothing nothing big happened and
definitely no threat so that victory
when Miesha Tate choked out Holly and
Holly's punching in the air like a
[ __ ] dramatic is that going out cold
punching in the air while she's going
out
and then Nate beating up Connor in that
second round after he gets [ __ ] up in
the first round beating him up in the
second round and then choking them
they're insane
probably the most exciting finishes to
any fight ever and the and the Connor
thing was just insane because he was on
a tear that was a you know one of the
biggest tears in MMA history and to
watch it go down like that especially
like you said like he was winning the
fight and the Nate turns it around yeah
and it was almost like on a drop of a
dime like Nate Nate like came to life in
that second round and starts talking
[ __ ] this is really fun in a home for
the jab
yeah headed with that big one too it was
only has a snake like one two two he
like what and then he like slithers
around you can't find him with a counter
he's really good and there's no one
worse than a Nate or Nick Diaz to get
hurt by in a fight because once they
hurt you they just like they push a pace
and then when you get hurt they like
pick it up and pick it up and then all
the sudden I mean before you know it
Connors hit like 25 [ __ ] times on the
beat and he's shooting for a takedown
those guys are always doing triathlons
so even though Nate is like it was taken
at fight 11 days notice and he wasn't in
shape he's still in way better shape
than most people so like him going five
rounds is not unfeasible it's not it's
not outside of the realm of imagination
he's in shape
there's nothing yeah the kind of shape
that he's gonna be when they have a
rematch and that becomes a real [ __ ]
problem is I think he's gonna beat him
up again well wouldn't need sad he's if
because I fired a camp you wouldn't
[ __ ] touch me
he goes my plan was to go out slow in
the first round and he came out fast
enough in the first round so I got
tagged a couple times but that's so cool
that's cool stick to the plan stick to
the plan and then the second round I
starts loosening up and opening up and
Connor was just dead yeah well I heard I
mean people were talking to Nate about
because you know going into that fight
like Connors power was what a lot of
people were talking about like you know
he put one punch on jose aldo's chin and
he's out and right no he's talking he's
like they can't handle my power I don't
do as well but he's Guevara and Nate was
saying in one of the post-fight
interviews we was like look I'm sparring
with Andre Ward and no shelling it like
heavyweight boxers I'm doing rounds with
heavyweight boxers yeah there's nothing
you're gonna hit him with that he hasn't
seen were kind of dealt with when he
split I like talking like Andre Ward and
Joe Schilling like
strike you're saying literally the best
the best yeah the best in boxing and the
best in kickboxing well Joe showing cuts
weight to kickbox at 185 pounds and
knocks dudes dead yeah
dead with one punch so that guy is
sparring with Nate on a regular basis
Andre Ward who is one of the best
[ __ ] boxers on the planet earth one
of the slickest said that Nate gives as
good as he gets when they split yeah
that's crazy and I think Joe Schilling I
might beginning but I think Joe
Schilling said he's never hurt either
one of them in a sparring session I
think he said that on a I'm fighter in
the kid I believe it tough [ __ ] dudes
man tough [ __ ] dudes but what what's
fascinating to me is that he wanted to
jump right back in there and do it again
and that Nate wanted or that Conor
wanted to just run it back and it's like
wow that's interesting it seems weird
that he gets to do that not so much that
he wants to but it just seems weird that
they were like like you know when Dana
White was talking about in his like look
man we tried to convince him to go down
to 145 and he was like Nate's field I
was like he's the matchmaker now he just
gets to go wouldn't you let him if you
want if you want to make a ton of money
right man I believe in the market yes
and that guy's that guy's what people
want to see he can do with you he can do
whatever he wants to do it needs a big
payday often but it's not just that the
emperor has been stripped down okay so
now he's exposed so now someone's beaten
him so here's the thing what do you do
now you want to make money okay because
if you want to make money make the
biggest fight you can right now while
he's been exposed and the biggest fight
for sure is when I say expose I don't
mean he's not talented
I mean exposed meaning he's a human and
he can lose and that happens with every
fighter they lose and once they lose
people go oh you can be beat you know we
saw it with Anderson Silva you saw with
Mike Tyson when after Mike Tyson fought
Buster Douglas it was a different world
everybody was like oh oh he's human so I
say exposed not in a disrespectful way
but got exposed
he lost get choked out he got beaten up
on the ground and then he got choked out
quick so this is not an invulnerable
perfect fighter who's unbelievably
durable right who can take punishment
like no man there's a lot of those guys
in the UFC
there's champions like that in the UFC
that like Robbie Lawler unbelievably
durable you can't put him a
way it's [ __ ] hard to put that guy
away we're not talking about that we're
talking about a guy who got dinged up
shot for a shitty wide open takedown got
taken down got demolished on the ground
and got choked unconscious quickly
afterwards so all right what do you do
could that happen with dos Anjos [ __ ]
yeah it could dos on just could do that
too it's possible I mean Conor might not
come out you never know Conor does have
that punch but you gotta put him in
against Nate again because that's the
big-money rematch and if if this guy
turns out to be a guy who's gonna win
some and lose some and the beginning of
his career this unbeatable wild Celtic
Warrior character right that's all gone
but he's champ he still got a belt at
145 yeah so it's almost kind of a right
a weird position for now but I mean
here's my question is when I say for now
can you really keep making that wait
that's what I'm saying well I I've
wondered about that too I've had some
people have argued with me saying like
no he can make the weight because he was
he was was in 169 against Nia so they're
saying he basically that's what he
starts at he can just cut down from
there that's a lot but look what he
looked like at the at the weigh-in so
maybe you can I mean he kind he
definitely can do it it's physically
possible I was so looking forward to the
press conference though just because I
can't you know you've got this guy in
Connor who's like the ultimate [ __ ]
talker and then you've got Nate who I
mean the first the dynamic at the first
press conference was amazing yeah it was
amazing and at that moment when he was
just like kind of talking circles around
Nate and they just broke and he goes how
about this [ __ ] you [ __ ] your belt [ __ ]
this press conference like they just
went to hang stir on him yeah but now
like how can Connor I was so interested
like how can he show up and talk [ __ ]
like that yeah when Nate's got the
perfect rebuttal that anything he has to
say I beat John this today's cosmic
saying all kinds of crazy stuff like the
first eight minutes were easy yeah
oh by mmm yeah but here's the difference
between the first day the last three
minutes the last three were a lot worse
yeah they were awful like you got [ __ ]
up man you got to just accept that but
that's part of his thing is that he has
to like look at things in the most
positive light possible and man I don't
know
I think stylistically it's a troublesome
fight for him because Nate is a very
clever boxer and his ground
game is a world away from where Connor
is right now and I've seen Nate roll
with guys he's a [ __ ] legit very
high-level Brazilian jiu-jitsu black
belt under a very respected camp his
cardio is outstanding his boxing is
nasty so where's Connor shining the only
way I think I mean I guess there's a you
know it's really hard to like fight a
Diaz brother and beat them usually when
people beat them it's kind of like
they're they really stick to a strategy
you got to kind of take them down and
avoid submissions or like leg kick and
circle like dos Anjos beat them up in
that way but you know what there's also
different show up well there's also you
know different camps you know you're
coming in who knows what kind of [ __ ]
injuries you're dealing with you know
you see a guy like Nate come in and look
really kind of lackadaisical against
half of those on just den you see him
come back and look shredded against
Michael Johnson and look sensational
so you go okay that's what he's capable
of when he's on and focused you got to
be ready for that guy and I think yeah
that's the best he's ever look at
Michael Johnson fight yeah you can't
think that the guy who lost dos Anjos is
showing up you got to think the guy that
came out swarmed cowboy in the first
round is coming like that that guy is a
clever [ __ ] boxer so where does Conor
shine knockout power that's where he
shines like Connor can dead dudes yeah
but but he couldn't do is yeah they're
tough to hit they have great head
movement and green chins and they they
roll with punches well the only guy to
ever stop Nate was Josh Thompson and
Josh did it with a brutal head kick and
Josh Thompson to this day I say is one
of the most underrated guys he just the
stars did not align for him but he could
have easily been a UFC champion he was
champ in a start horse yeah and with
Gilbert and him and Gilbert went back
and forth you know Josh Thompson's
world-class fighters so when Josh
Thompson head kicked him you know it's
like Josh to do that to anybody in that
division if he catches you you know
you're [ __ ] he sees the older now and
he's just yeah I think he's a guy that
like like I said the stars didn't like
perfectly aligned for but like skill
wise and technique wise he's a [ __ ]
world-class fighter so when he knocked
out Nate Diaz it's not necessarily an
indication that Nate Diaz is done
because just you know that's how good
Josh Thompson is yeah and at the time
and then so Nate rebounds from that and
I think people you look at like the
losses
the dos anjos fight and you look at that
the Josh Thompson fight and you go hmm
how good is he you know I could beat
that guy but then you look at the
Michael Johnson fighting Oh whoo that
that guy's [ __ ] dangerous
Jay Miller Cerrone exact a lot of these
fighters just unbelievable yeah uh and I
think uh it's one of those things where
styles make fights and you know kind of
really got in people's heads by talking
[ __ ] and I felt like going and I was
like I think you're gonna get Nate's
head by talking [ __ ] he's not that guy
yeah how about this Mike will [ __ ] up
your whole crew that's the most gangster
thing you could say by the way that's
the most gangster thing cuz he's
literally just going will [ __ ] jump
you dude not like we're not playing
around here yeah and all those guys even
the guys who seemed like kind of nice
guys and his team like Jake Shields if
you like he'll [ __ ] jump you like
those guys are a vegetarian it'll kick
your ass
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]